for some reason that i cannot fathom
tucker carlson invited candace owens to
analyze and interpret the three guilty
verdicts uh for former police officer
derek chovin
who of course killed george floyd last
year yesterday we covered live those
three guilty verdicts and what's funny
about this is that
candace owens has no idea about anything
it's not clear to me why she comments
about anything
never mind jury trials owens has become
sort of a conservative darling in some
circles as a
i guess former liberal who found
conservatism and of course
being a black woman even though the
right is against identity politics
being a black woman gives her a
particularly useful identity to the
american
right wing but watching her melt down
and just grasp at straws is both
entertaining but it's also a reminder
that tons of people will see
this they will see uh what candace owens
what you are about to see from candace
owens
and because they are unable to think for
themselves they will
accept it hook line and sinker and
that's a very dangerous reality
let's take a look at the first clip can
assoins you'd think in a country like
ours
very top i mean this is the most first
world country that's ever been you think
the most civilized
and the most just here you have to
consider a
murder case through the lens of politics
when you get to that point haven't you
already
given up civilization that's correct and
what we're really seeing is mob justice
and and that's really what happened with
this entire trial this was not a trial
about george floyd or derek chovin
this was a trial about whether the media
was powerful enough to create a
simulation and decide upon a narrative
absent any facts
it's almost like she didn't watch the
trial where
fact after fact after medical fact and
documentary evidence
were introduced mob justice what is she
talking about
and she gets even more divorced from
reality the longer she's allowed to keep
speaking and answering the same question
whether it was powerful enough to repeat
showing and talking about
a nine-minute clip that came from
somebody's cell phone without adding any
contacts without showing the full
you know the full police video which
they could have released they refused to
release the full body cam which
would have added more clarity now this
is sort of slippery
she throws in that the video of george
floyd being killed is from a cell phone
so what what difference does it make
that is from a cell phone
rather than cctv footage rather than 4k
or whatever and then she gish gallops
right into
the body cam footage wasn't even
revealed
the absence of body cam footage doesn't
change this
from a guilty verdict into a not guilty
verdict
it's possible that if the body cam
footage was released
it might have shown something different
or it might have shown the same thing
probably the same thing based on the
sort of clear-cut nature of the video we
do have
but the absence of a video doesn't
actually make the verdict wrong and it
doesn't make it mob justice and more
importantly with how
frequently body cam footage is quote
lost
or unavailable due to technical problems
if there were no cell phone video for
all we know
there'd be no video at all and we'd have
zero accountability
it is rare that you actually have such
an incident
where there are witnesses and video when
you were talking about the death of
someone
understand that you know the vast
majority of homicides
um there's just no video and and cases
don't have
the documentary evidence that that we
had here okay let's watch one more clip
um to the fact that the media was lying
you know the media came out let's not
forget this tucker the media came out
and told us
that this was a man who was just getting
his life together he was a good
you know good member of society and he
got mixed up because
a racist white police officer had it out
for him and and killed him
all of that fell apart those actually
are not statements that really have
anything to do with the trial
you had jury selection derek chauvin's
attorney had every opportunity to strike
jurors
potential jurors if he felt that they
had prejudged the case that they already
believed that derek chovin was guilty or
whatever
there was a fair jury selection process
floyd turning his life around or not
is not actually relevant to the case
she is completely off the rails uh let's
actually watch a little bit more here
all the facts came out and all of that
fell apart we now know of course
that he had enough fentanyl in him it
was three times the lethal dosage three
times lethal dosage in him when he died
but nobody cares
doctors testified very specifically
during the trial
george floyd did not die of a fentanyl
overdose
this is trash it is nonsense
but people are already repeating this
stuff on twitter and elsewhere
one more clip because the media was
successful and putting out a narrative
and they kept hitting that narrative and
the reason why democrats are happy is
because they realize of course
the media supports them and now means
the democrats can get whatever they want
because they can create a narrative and
then they can treat people like pawns
and get them to basically say
if we don't get what we want we will
riot we will loot
we will send these people out like
soldiers to destroy your
neighborhoods and that is exactly what
has happened that has been the
determination
of this trial the media and the
democrats now have enough power
to bully to bully and to lie to and to
create propaganda
and to successfully win and that is what
happened and they are celebrating that
win today
this was not a fair trial no person can
say this was a fair trial
she's just completely out of control and
who is she to say if the trial was fair
there was jury selection and both sides
had a chance to weigh in on jurors they
accepted the slate of jurors
the judge is there they will get a
chance to appeal if they want but she
just decided that this is not a fair
trial
it's actually a tragedy that candace
owens is interviewed as some kind of
expert i guess on what i don't know
democrats are happy
this is the sort of don jr liberals want
people to die of covid uh to hurt trump
thing no one's happy about this i don't
take joy at people going to prison i'm
against imprisoning people
uh as a sort of general principle it's
horrifying that this trial even had to
take place
i would rather uh derek chauvin
uh be a a good police officer and george
floyd be alive
but george floyd is not alive and
accountability is necessary but
what i do enjoy is the right wing
melting down
over this verdict and we're going to
look at some more examples uh
momentarily
one of our sponsors is privacy.com
they're giving you five dollars when you
sign up for their
completely free service at privacy.com
pacman i've been using privacy for a
little over a year now you've heard me
talk about it before
it's a lifesaver and here's how it works
takes just a couple of minutes to set up
anytime you buy something
online or on the phone instead of
actually using your real credit card
number the privacy app
and the browser plug-in let you give
each company
a randomized virtual credit card number
that you create
out of thin air it'll even autofill the
card number with one click
and the payment is taken out of your
checking account
without the merchant ever knowing your
real information
so this allows you to keep your banking
information secure but also to take
control of your finances you can create
up to 12 of these virtual credit cards
a month you can set spending limits you
can freeze them
you can delete them anytime you want so
when you do this
it means you're not going to be charged
when you don't want to be
because you can destroy the virtual card
number
right after using it which for instance
i love using free trials because i know
i won't be charged when the trial is
over
if i use a virtual credit card number
you're keeping your identity private
by not telling companies who you are
you're keeping your bank or
credit card info protected against data
breaches and identity theft
and it's free and like i said you'll get
five dollars to
spend when you sign up at privacy.com
slash pacman